for many becoming an actor is the
ultimate dream job but most of these
performers had their sights set
elsewhere
School of Rock was a film that helped
prove Jack Black was more than just a
gimmick he had appeared in movies before
and found plenty of success with his
musical group Tenacious D but this was a
flick that helped transform him into a
household name what truly makes him
shine in school of rock is the way he
works with his reluctant bandmates and
of that group of students who are a few
kids as memorable as Lawrence the
keyboard Maestro played by Robert Tsai
Lawrence is one of the most skilled
performers in the band berta's
insecurities nearly derail his
opportunities I don't think I should be
in the band
why not
I'm not cool enough
according to school of rock director
Richard link later he drew on a real
interaction with Robert Psy for
Lawrence's emotional scene Sia
apparently tried to quit the film
telling link later that he thought he
was unfit for the role the director
convinced him to stay and we worked that
conversation into a scene where Lawrence
expressed his concern that he's not cool
enough to be in the band Sai never acted
again after school of rock but he
continued to perform as a classical
pianist
for a bit of childhood Wonder look no
further than Willy Wonka and the
Chocolate Factory the 1971 movie is
remembered for many things including
Gene Wilder's iconic purple suited
chocolatier a number of deceptive traps
some very ominous songs and the
blue-eyed hero of it all Charlie Bucket
played by Peter Ostrom Charlie proves
her selflessness to Wonka and wins the
day sparking hope for his destitute
family when he is awarded Wonka's
factory Ostrom told the Journal of the
American Veterinary Medical Association
that after playing the role of Charlie
he was offered a three-film deal by the
studio if he signed with them however he
declined in order to keep his options
open and give himself more freedom
although he did audition for a few more
roles as he got older Ostrum was drawn
to the world of veterinary medicine he
eventually moved to New York and claimed
to distance himself from the movie
rarely telling people about that part of
his life first as he's grown older he's
embraced that aspect of his history
especially the mentoring relationship he
had with Wilder
Steven Spielberg's Hook is finally
remembered for its incredible cast and
firmly imagining of the classic Peter
Pan story who can forget Dustin
Hoffman's scenery chewing Captain Hook
performance or Robin Williams Peter Pan
and his playful banter with Julia
Roberts Tinkerbell the boo-box run home
Jack Rufio we're talking about a stone
cold classic right here
looky looky I got hooky often lost in
the shuffle as Peter's daughter Maggie
played by then seven-year-old Amber
Scott Maggie has seen stealing moments
throughout the film but despite her
terrific performance Scott's only other
acting credits as a voice actor on the
historical documentary series American
Experience Scott seemingly went on to a
normal life as she Grew Older attending
Trinity College and getting her degree
she eventually updated a headshot on
IMDb and received a producer credit for
the short film Cannonball maybe she's
still gearing up for a return to
Hollywood but we haven't heard anything
in a few years from her Camp there are
only a handful of films that commonly
get mentioned in debates over the best
sci-fi movies of all time but aliens is
generally on the short list released in
1986 it leans hard into his high octane
action to tell an entirely different
story than his predecessor one that
still holds up as a classic today aliens
is largely successful because of the
very relatable relationship between
Ripley and news for scared little girl
she protects from the xenomorph Menace
play by Carrie hand Newt gives the
audience a surrogate character who is
just as terrified in the face of an
Interstellar monster as we would be
fighting to stay alive against all the
odds despite her strong performance the
timing just didn't work out for him
after aliens was released her family had
already moved from London to the United
States he told Wyatt that she had grown
more interested in becoming an educator
than an actor leading her to her career
as an elementary teacher even so hen
Embraces her legendary role you can
capture at conventions and she is happy
to sign autographs for her students when
they realize who she is the American
Road movies poster child is Easy Rider
but there's a number of films that fit
the category one that often flies under
the radar is two-lane blacktop a
minimalistic film about a Duo of Road
Racers who flit across the country in
their Chevy 150. single-songwriter James
Taylor and beach boys drummer Dennis
Wilson play the lead roles and while
Taylor assistant's sporadic acting in
his career Wilson only made this one
appearance on film Wilson may have been
primed for a successful career with both
a musician and an actor but one unlucky
encounter seemed to derail his life The
Beach Boys drummer had a habit of
picking up hitchhikers and one day he
brought two young women back to his home
after leaving him for a recording
session he came back to his house to
discover the women had invited even more
people over one of them was a young
Charles Manson as Wilson's life was
slowly eroded by Manson and his Cults he
turned a heavy substance abuse he died
at the age of 39 drowning after diving
into Marina Del Rey though not as
impactful as The Omen the sequel is
vastly superior to the third and fourth
entries in the franchise and we don't
even bother with the 2006 remake in
Damien Omen 2 everyone's favorite
Antichrist has a pre-teen living with
his uncle in Chicago and attending a
military academy the only semblance of a
true friend he has is his cousin Mark
played by Lucas donat when Mark learns
Damien's true nature and confronts him
Damien gives him the chance to join him
Mark refuses and Damien kills his cousin
in order to protect his secret after
leaving the acting profession Donna
became a prolific advertising executive
for tiny Rebellion a firm that won the
2014 small agency award from ad age
dinette has been praised for his
disruptive approach and for helping to
spearhead the marketing campaigns for
companies like LegalZoom and eHarmony
foreign